cardi b captured a precious moment with
offset and their baby boy
she's so cute i love her the rapper
caught offset cradling their
four-month-old son thursday morning with
the little one even reaching out toward
his dad's face
cardi shared the video to her instagram
story adding the caption quote he being
mean to me he want to be with his daddy
i already fell in love uh the way that
he was a dad already i'm like oh my god
i can have a little one with this guy
he's really good he's really good but as
the mother of two tells it the newborn
hasn't been on his best behavior
today
this one right here
has not been a good boy
first uh he woke up i think like one
hour earlier than he usually do
and then he took like three hours
three hours yep the message ended right
at that moment maybe cardi got
distracted by some more baby talk
i'm not exaggerating
this baby is talking
i i put this on everything i love in the
name of jesus christ the grammy winner
opened up about the milestone moment on
wednesday first of all my husband saw it
um
yesterday i was like you love mommy yeah
ask him again you love mommy and he
replied back like yeah like not even
like
it was like yeah
according to cardi her little guy wasn't
done by a long shot
and then just now like he's watching
coco melon and they're like if you happy
to say hello hello if you're happy you
know i say hello and then like when they
stop he said oh
yo this is crazy this is crazy like
i need a i need a camera in this room 24
7 or something because
yo you talking
and you just turned 4 months today you
talking for real cardian offset welcomed
their little bundle of joy to the world
on september 4th i love everything about
motherhood last summer on barty gang
radio cardio opened up about when she
discovered she was pregnant even sharing
how offset reacted to the big news
it was like two weeks before grammys i
was still in rehearsal you know i get a
lot headache but like i just started
like my mouth started to get real watery
and i started getting real carsick and
everything when you told
offset and culture
that you were pregnant what was their
initial reaction and i was like
i think i'm pregnant bro
and when cardi let her daughter culture
know that she was going to be a big
sister she got this adorable response
so culture like this baby in there it's
baby
it's babies like she knows it's a baby
so she like don't jump on me like she
was too